-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight
and now, we, if you don't mind,
are going to get to the news.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden attended
a funeral today
at the National Cathedral
and this is a shame --
it was for the
infrastructure bill.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden reportedly
held a phone call Monday night
with House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
and Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
to discuss the debt ceiling
and it worked!
They all slept like babies.
[ Laughter ]
In her new book,
ex-White House Press Secretary
Stephanie Grisham said
that former President Trump's
anger was "terrifying,"
which makes sense
because so was his joy.
[ Laughter ]
According to the same book,
former President Trump would
listen to the song "Memory"
from the musical "Cats"
whenever he was upset.
Of course,
he would just get angrier
when Lindsey Graham
would forget the words.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Graham ]
The song's about memory,
but the irony is that's one
of my worst qualities.
[ Laughter ]
During his testimony yesterday
before the Senate,
Joint Chiefs of Staff Chairman
General Mark Milley said
that he told
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi,
after the January attack
on the Capitol, that he was,
"not qualified to determine the
mental health of the president."
I don't know.
I think we all are.
It's like watching "Joker"
and saying,
"I think something's up
with him, but I'm not a doctor."
[ Laughter ]
During his testimony,
Milley called the
U.S. withdrawal from Afghanistan
a "logistical success,
but a strategic failure."
Sort of like
when you buy your wife
a table saw for Valentine's Day.
Logistically,
you got her a gift,
but, strategically...
mistakes were made.
[ Laughter ]
After passing Jeff Bezos
this week
to, once again, become the
world's richest person,
Tesla CEO Elon Musk said
he was going to send Bezos
a silver medal
and a statue of the number 2,
but, then, it turned out
the only way to do that was
with Amazon.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Bill de Blasio
visited Rikers Island jail
this week and said,
"This is a place that should
have been shut down
a long time ago."
Said an employee,
"This is LaGuardia."
[ Laughter ]
[ As de Blasio ]
Ah, makes sense.
I didn't think
Rikers would have a Cinnabon.
[ Laughter ]
Producers have announced
that the TV series "Law & Order"
will return for its 21st season.
See, they made you think
it's Dick Wolf's idea,
but, turns out, it was his wife.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, nearly 12 years
after the original series
was canceled,
producers have announced
that the original "Law & Order"
will return to NBC
for its 21st season.
Wow!
So, Trump said
he was going to bring back
law and order,
but Biden actually did it.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced yesterday
that disgraced actress
Lori Loughlin
will return to acting
for the first time
since serving two months
in prison
for her role in the
college admissions scandal.
But that's not
why she's disgraced.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
U.S. wildlife officials
announced today
that 22 animals and one plant
have become extinct.
That's right,
22 animals and one plant.
Or, as it's also known,
jambalaya.
[ Laughter ]
You told me it made sense.
That was a monologue, everybody.